now with Teresa May insisting she's
seeking a fresh mandate to help secure
the best brexit deal possible the man on
whose shoulders much of the
responsibility lies admits it won't be
an easy job we shall be under no
illusions about the scale of the task
ahead of us we are reshaping Britain's
place in the world securing an agreement
with the EU within the two-year period
about our withdrawal and the shape of
our future relationship will be
challenging
we'll have difficult issues to confront
compromises be necessary on both sides
we know all this and even as the
election campaign proceeds the work of
government goes on to prepare for the
negotiations the brexit secretary was
speaking at the launch of prosperity UK
a conference bringing together both
leave and remain supporters aiming to
make brexit a success dozens of business
leaders MPs trade experts and academics
were there and I spoke to some of them
the city is obviously center stage in
this debate as you know in manufactured
goods we have a very big trade deficit
with Europe about 80 billion euro a year
so I think in manufactured goods funnily
enough we'll get a trade deal pretty
easily because they sell more to us than
we sell to them on financial services we
are major net exporter about 40 billion
euro and that is going to be much more
difficult it is quite obvious from some
of the rhetoric that we read in the
press that certain politicians in Europe
not all but certain of them see that the
brexit is an opportunity for them
effectively to grab financial services
from London to take them back to Paris
or Frankfurt or Amsterdam or ever and
this is a very complex issue and clearly
an issue which we discussed today and we
have to think through how london UK
negotiates those issues in the brexit
discussions well executive search is
going from strength
because uncertainty means you need top
talent and good people search in the UK
has always been incredibly international
a third of our channel and a third of
our chief executives are not British
they're not necessarily European they
come from all around the world and I
think what people want to be sure is it
still be possible for Britain to attract
top talent from anywhere in the world
the commitment from the minister
responsible today was exactly that more
controlled immigration but certainly we
need to be a magnet for talent
innovation and success and you're not
seeing any hesitation on the part of
international executives about coming to
the UK not really I mean some of the
banks have been saying they're making
contingency plans but then nobody's
anticipating a mass exodus business will
always head fair bet but the opportunity
is far outweigh the threats we are in a
negotiation process and so to be
optimistic would be I think ignoring the
fact that this is going to be a long and
probably volatile process what I am
confident about is that people are
engaging on it and are really trying to
be pragmatic and look beyond politics to
come to have outcomes I think it's
really business as usual still the UK is
a huge economy it's an important economy
both for asset management and for
insurance as the rest of the financial
services sector we've got many many
customers that are global customers who
need coverage for their businesses here
so know it's continuing business as
usual in trade there is a very big
opportunity for the Britain to become
world's beacon of free trade trade
global trade is stalled for the last 10
years a share of GNP and largely because
all the trade deals have been around
manufacturing and the next challenge is
to do services in agriculture and there
is the potential for Britain to lead the
way in doing a services for agriculture
deal and we are obviously one of the
world's leading services economy I am
really optimistic about the future of
financial services in the you know
Kingdom for one particular reason the
ecosystem that we have created here in
the UK is unique it combines many many
values and inherent strengths that come
from years and years decades and decades
of industries combining and working
together you combine that with the legal
framework that we have here the
regulatory setup
combining with just the access to talent
that we have in the United Kingdom gives
me a load of optimism about the future
of financial services